hello and welcome to this video playing
team glute again plating just earlier in
the session so now you place them the
bloody Italian game I had this early in
where would you had this and I think in
a live stream right Rosa the game well
as mentioned numerous times i think this
is bad for white so let's see let's see
what mr. glute is doing yeah heh move so
we can take g for I cannot take
immediately but I can do this an IG for
next pre moon is a little bit dicey it
may be but like almost possible so here
I am what would I what I what do we have
here I can taking taken only three looks
a bit weird I can take here
hmm interesting you can take on h2 I
cannot I cannot easily move the Queen
and because of mf7 being weak
okay maybe do this in ambition 26
there's an intake with a pawn I thought
that was the idea okay um anyway yeah I
would have liked to Castle long hair but
didn't work out
so what's going on here don't quite get
anything um to try to really snatch the
pawn down maybe is
I'm not concerned about the porn but I
was thinking and thinking of doubling
read doubling later
get anything Queen g5 run-up material up
here I mean I am clearly by counting but
I mean for a little for little
compensation right there three coming
one character here
the rate of moves that expected and was
really the win this game really really
low um so what to do here
so you threatening to take on f4 here or
not so much room
maybe I should just cover it all let's
just cover it the knight on c6 isn't
doing anything at all when do i activate
how to activate this piece if i go 98
somehow sometime he might have quinta CA
96 queen bee 7 hmm maybe maybe King back
to the age and then nitey 72 g 62 h for
this looks like a plan yeah that looks
like a decent plan rookie to this is
even more encouraged to get the King out
of this file
let's go for that it goes 'if I've Luke
is six I'm gaining at five for the night
this should be okay
so to pin now if it takes I take you to
some Knight to f3 is this idea okay if I
just go d5 here let's just close this
actually night f5 to age four or three
three for that matter
tonight each for that was my plan like a
couple of months ago I asked g4 at the
end what kind of stuff is dad mad eh
forget 492 looked you fly morning what
kind of crap don't tell me I have a good
move I have no good movie Ellen would be
absolutely crazy I don't see one okay i
don't see a good affair that's crazy
that's absolutely crazy
check
and this is hanging now Andrew you
success mate it's just mate unbelievable
wow I will give a dismayed now who gave
a his maid didn't see it Rukia 27 made
check checkmate wow that was terrible
and really weird I mean it was just
going in circles in this in this
position and somehow I didn't still did
with I mean this is like completely
shuffling around Athens idea to go to
age 40 k 95 house I mean but I don't
believe don't tell me that this isn't
great for black here I didn't find
something at age 5 at the end Soneji
three wins yeah but why and how I
because of nitey to check and I can go
to you for so here I've usually it's
simple but I don't see it slow I was so
irritated that this doesn't work yeah
you know because it was my will plan and
then we'll yet stuff like that or you
can even take now here yeah because this
is hanging anyway yeah I have to go here
and then it's basically gone for them
they cannot take because of 92 oh yeah
something something like that is just
too terrible yeah ok so this h3 line and
I think it's not particularly great then
why does giving up the initiative and I
know I don't like it so yeah still I was
expecting to take with the porn yet so
counterplay maybe this is stronger it's
possible so we have a position that the
computer thinks it's roughly equal
yeah I don't know this is that didn't
get I think I mean here that cannot be
great for wide right it's equal
according to the computer Queen f3
smacking position really that big of a
deal and old Knight f3 is actually the
move okay so the engine wants to go to
h4 here like this 495 okay now he
actually this is a business losing in
exchange okay ma okay okay okay no I'll
point taken up point taken right except
probably than 97 s better okay if I
cannot quickly get the rook around
energy far then this is well ATM son
idea three was good for him change here
yeah here he is slowly and surely
position is getting worse and worse and
he was basically just going back and
forth while I was improving just playing
just playing 93 m and here I'm lost him
there was nothing much in between you
either win with 93 or you lose yeah
pretty awful ya hear that lab London
made nobody it's it's completely gone as
you forgot to switch this on again yeah
it happens especially if i'm kind of
annoyed by the game yeah so i don't know
if it is helpful to see it now again you
hear I just the key witness just one key
moment h5 is it's nonsense and that took
like 50 seconds I'm Carol already here
it's equal time just stupid the lagg-3
was basically oops come on ending the
thing if I get to you for this is just
too terrible and you cannot take because
of the tragic
bad okay thanks for watching guys